[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
corinne présidents des républiques
enscene france bonsoir à paris merci
d'être avec nous ce jour important pour
vous on imagine jean eric branaa
spécialisés les états unis de
conférences à l'université assas paris 2
bonsoir merci également à vous d'être
avec nous palin
juste pour savoir vous regarder ça avec
une certaine fébrilité ou une simple
curiosité en tant que républicain qui
veut est sûr de gagner vous vous l'avais
déjà dit non mais là je vous taquine
vous avez regardé ça avec quel oeil ce
soir oui curiaces était bien sûr c'est
important c'est le super mad et mardi
c'est le primaire de jour le plus
important pendant pour les démos cas les
primaires démocrates
et maintenant tout a changé parce
qu'avant c'était que pénis 1,2 en tête
et maintenant joe banner est revenu de
la mort on peut dire son compagnon était
presque mois et après le caire nid du
sud
maintenant c'est très serré donc jo bein
peuvent même gagner
de plus elle était dévote ce soit donc
ça serait ça change tout
j'en ai que branagh c'est la magie de
ces primaires démocrates à mort pourrait
susciter d'ailleurs c'est joe biden qui
nie l'importance est toujours de se
relever et a réussi en tout cas ce pari
oui moi je n'ai pas vu très molle je
crois qu'il faut quand même raison
garder là dessus mais c'est en réalité
on a un narratif le narratif qui dit que
après l'iowa
on regarde les résultats alors que l'aïe
ouest un tout petit et à 3 millions
personnes qui représentent pas grand
chose le new hampshire
un million de personnes c'est encore
plus petit et et le nevada commencé à me
donner une indication ce qui pouvait se
passer effectivement parce que c'était
plus important dans l'amérique profonde
et diverses mais là
la caroline du sud est venu remettre les
pendules à l'heure et ce soir elles vont
être vraiment à l'heure puisque pour le
coup on va avoir l'ensemble de
l'amérique de toutes les diversités qui
vont être présentés
donc c'est vrai que là on a une vraie
une vraie photo g
il est majeur sans l'être en réalité oui
puisque un tiers des délégués
il faut gagner des délégués pour pouvoir
avoir l'investiture 1991
mais lola maintien délégués vont être
distribués mais en réalité derrière il
ya encore un autre super tuesday mardi
prochain et encore un autre le mardi
d'après avec des grands états le
michigan la semaine prochaine la floride
la fois d'après et si ils sont pas très
loin l'un de l'autre je parle de bernie
sanders et joe biden en réalité dans les
2 mardi qu'ils vont venir c'est très
favorable à un job hayden parce que on
va avoir beaucoup d'états dont sud et
juste dans quinze jours avec la floride
où il y aura une très grosse timbale et
là où thunder n'a quasiment aucune
chance
historiquement qu'est ce que ça dit ce
superbe sautée
on peut presque connaître déjà le visage
qui se dessine tout doucement du
prochain candidat démocrate ou c'est un
petit peu prématuré de dire ça non c'est
pas vraiment prématuré
chaque fois super tube comme générique à
dire à d autres mains des mets jamais su
percuter avec 13 14 de ta et surtout
avec la californie le texas en même
temps oui exactement californie avant
c'était le premier ryanair californie et
dont le 3 mars super tuesday à il a
voulu d'avoir plus n'aime pas que les
primaires donc il y aura d autres jours
mais avec quatre ou cinq états plus
petits avec une très grosse new york
floride mais je n'ai jamais néant
comme ce soit et les deux consultations
californie qui a plus de 400 elle est
déléguée à gagner et après taxes plus de
200 d'encre et 2 très présent contrat
justement on va s'arrêter quelques
instants sur le texas un fief on peut
lire des républicains depuis maintenant
plus de trente ans l'occasion pour les
démocrates peuvent être de prendre de
l'avancé face aux républicains de trump
en novembre prochain le texas qui risque
peut-être de bouleverser les forces
politiques américaines samedi martin un
pari fou qui pouvait faire basculer les
résultats de la présidentielle
ce super tuesday devient un enjeu
primordial dans l'échiquier politique
autant pour les républicains que pour
les démocrates
l'enjeu du texas deuxième état le plus
peuplé des états unis fief des
républicains depuis les années 80 fait
de l'oeil aux candidats démocrates
alors que l'état n'a pas voté pour un
prétendant démocrate à la présidence
depuis 1976
le nouveau visage démographique du texas
qui a vu sa population latino américaine
triplé en une génération risque de
rabattre les cartes alors beaucoup de
gens disent que le texas est un état
rouge mais c'est faux qui est un état où
les gens ne votent pas c'est pourquoi
nous voulons nous assurer que nous
touchons le plus de gens possible est
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles nous
avons décidé d'organiser une tournée et
d'entrer en contact avec ces communautés
qui ne sont habituellement pas touchés
par les campagnes les jeunes électeurs
latinos sont le futur donc seulement du
texas mais des états unis dans ce pays
toutes les 30 secondes un latino fête
ses 18 ans dans les dix prochaines
années
nous deviendrons la majorité de la
population du pays il est impératif que
tout candidat qui cherche à gagner
commence à donner la priorité à cet
électorat
si les démocrates réussissent à arracher
en novembre prochain l'état à donald
trump
cela risquerait bien de mettre en
difficulté le président jusqu'à leur
confiant une inquiétude partagée par les
républicains si on perd le texas nous
n'aurons plus jamais de président
républicain de notre vivant si le tarn
county tombe le texas tombe
et si le texas tombe adieu donald trump
les résultats du texas pourrait bien
être la grande surprise de l'élection
présidentielle l'état ne serait plus
essentiellement rouge couleur des
républicains mais pourrait devenir un
métissage politique tirant sur le bleu
des démocrates
raymond a vu ses inquiétudes ses propos
alarmistes des républicains si le texas
tombe on aura plus donald trump et plus
de républicains de notre vivant vous
partager ses inquiétudes
je n'ai aucune inquiété pour l'élection
générale je vous parle du texas là ses
propos assez haut rédhibitoire sur le
thème relations père le texas il est
républicain perdre le texas
donald trump non non je n'ai pas peu de
texte s'est pas complètement rouge comme
malade et mais ces textes quand même un
soutien très fort dans notre chambre
mais tant que c'est très important pour
le primaire et je crois que britney for
science a gagné texte brunissant de
californie est en avance en californie
mais je crois que ben ayed nation sagan
et ex face à tresses intéressant
jean-eric votre je suis beaucoup plus
mesurée que paul là dessus effectivement
le texas est en pleine mutation
actuellement d'abord en ce moment il ya
un recensement et on sait qu'à la fin de
ce rang seulement 1,5 cette année le
texas qui a gagné effectivement beaucoup
d'habitants va avoir beaucoup de
représentants plémentaires trois
exactement ça veut dire qu'on va
redistribuer les circonscription
redécoupée aux états unis et cette
différence cette redistribution va va se
faire au détriment des républicains
parce qu'effectivement ces
circonscriptions s'agrandissent parce
que l'on d'habitants qui est englobé à
s'agrandit et ça profite aux démocrates
il est vrai aussi que les
hispanique qui ne votent pas là dessus
je suis assez d'accord avec ce qui a été
dit commence quand même à aller vers le
bulletin de vote et à l'occasion de
cette élection il pourrait bien y avoir
un mouvement qui fait qu'ils
s'inscrivent davantage parce qu'il ya un
rejet de donald trump qui est très très
fort alors peut-être que ça donnera pas
un résultat tout de suite sur 2020 mais
en tout cas sur 2024 ou 2028 le texas
effectivement devrait basculer
et quand li na rézon le jour où le texas
bascule parce qu'il ya 38 grands
électeurs et bien c'est très difficile
pour les républicains de pouvoir penser
à avoir un président c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que djordje de bouche
pardon jeff beauchamp la dernière fois
expliqué qu'il fallait se pencher vers
le vote hispanique et essayer de séduire
les hispaniques lui qui est du texas qui
était qui est marié à une mexicaine et
c'était la stratégie de parti
républicain avant que trains n'arrivent
parle de son mur parle de ce rejet des
hispaniques et il y a une vraie coupure
aujourd'hui entre le parti républicain
et cette population si je peux le dire
on parle jamais que de l'est les
pressantes hd et hispanique aux états
unis qui soutient d'un an qui chante
maintenant
donc non il peut parler ces derniers
temps avec justement ces bons résultats
économiques et puis elle est mobilisée
pour les minorités de trouver du travail
en font partie oui exactement dans le
sens pas c'est pas que des hispaniques
nous allons voir maintenant si il a
gagné moins de 10% des f&a franken en
2016 et maintenant il ya plus de 20% qui
se tient dans mon champ d'onal décida de
porter des hispaniques les arbalètes
c'était c'était vers 20% qu'il a gagné
maintenant les sondages c'est c'est plus
que ça c'est entre 20 et 30% à main sur
l'essai mais si c'était ça il est le cas
problèmes pour se faire élire mais on en
n'est effectivement pas à des chiffres
comme ça
le pourcentage de 10 panique qui
soutient donald trump est toujours aussi
bas il n'a pas bougé depuis son élection
non et concernant les afro américains
ont sonné à 9
pour ça on est pris demain 20h à 20 % 20
% ce serait un chiffre uniquement
extraordinaire c'est un peu comme bernie
sanders qui expliqué qu'ils étaient
soutenus par la comité nobel toruk mais
c'est comme ça c'est une injection
nouvelle intrigue oric et à une amende
et hispanique aux états unis qui sont
sont plus stables avec l'économie ils
ont emmené les boulots ils sont en
colère avec cette institution du
talentueux et vous verrez que juste
parce qu'il ya des hispaniques en taxi
ça ne dira pas que les hispaniques va à
voter pour les démocrates
alors on le disait un de 14 états qui
votent en même temps des étapes
différentes et que ça s'en vient en par
les californiens on a un peu parlé mais
sa chaussette alabama vous avez commencé
tout à l'heure à faire cette analyse
mais ce que ça reflète vraiment la
diversité sociale et économique du pays
est ce que ça donne une bonne
photographie de ce que sont les états
unis aujourd'hui jean eric branaa rui
absolument d'un boronat les états du sud
alors c'est réel très éclectique on
passe par le l'oklahoma l'alabama le
texas on en a dit on en a parlé
l'arkansas mais on monte jusqu'au
minnesota donc on est au nord des états
unis on va de l'autre côté à l'est
connecticut vers main et massachusetts
et à l'ouest on à l'ugta le colorado et
la californie comment voulez-vous faire
plus diversifiée on a tous les coins des
états unis en réalité toutes les
populations donc c'est vrai que la
photographie la photographie qu'on va
voir demain matin va être extraordinaire
parce que c'est à peu près la
photographie qui se reproduira à peu
près partout
après effectivement avec des forces
différentes suivant les uns et les
autres
alors parlons des protagonistes
effectivement bernie sanders qui avait
longtemps enfin longtemps en ce sens de
parler enfin en tout cas qui fait la
course en tête dans les sondages mais
joe biden qui semble vous l'avais dit à
le rattraper avec la victoire en
caroline du sud vous en tant que
républicain
vous espériez qui justement question est
oui mais qui vous fait le plus peur
finalement face à donald trump en
novembre c'est difficile à dire pour moi
je voudrais vraiment voir il n'a une
course de socialisme compte capitalisme
donc bernie saint denis c'est un
contre-temps et les vrais débats parce
qu'il y a c'est vrai que bruni siens 2-1
en gros une petite armée d surtout les
jeunes les jeunes qui croient que les
choses et il croit que les idées de
socialistes sont très bien ça vous
étonne justement ces jeunes qui
soutiennent farouchement bernie sanders
qui est quand même pas effectivement le
plus peut-être le plus fringant de tous
les candidats
c'est étonnant selon vous c'est
maintenant attendons pour moi parce que
en termes de qu'il soutient socialisme
parce que les professeurs d'université
il pousse cette idée que socialisme et
+10 gouvernance et une meilleure idée
capitalisme c'est les problèmes dans le
monde et c'est mai donc je suis pas
supprimées à je suis pas sûr que bernie
va gagner maintenant avec ce que tu ne
sais pas juste popularité de jubail mais
c'est le parti est très divisée entre
entre deux entre modérés si on peut dire
je crois pas que iad est vraiment de ré
dont le parti démocratique démocrates
mais le mot dray et l'extrême gauche et
les mots dray et il a exclu un peu près
tout le temps mais grâce à les gens qui
sont vient d'arrêter le convaincant
meilleur piqué et aymeric robin cher par
exemple elle vient de menace heures de
temps qu'un soutien d'un bind on va
probablement gagner mais nos soldats
donc c'est très divisée en ce moment
dans payne un gros chance à gagner donc
on verra
jean eric branaa parler de norbert
descendeur d'abord est un autoproclamé
socialiste
puisque il est pas très socialiste non
plus fait le con paris acquis par
exemple en france quelle ligne parce
qu'alors paul ring nous parler d'extrême
gauche c'est s'asseoir et jean luc
mélenchon ça va ça va même trop loin par
rapport à ce qui est bernie sanders et
est un social démocrate un emmanuel
c'est mais c'est quoi ces madames c'est
un social-démocrate et accueillir oui
même si je peux les aider
l'extrême gauche aux états unis est
toujours beaucoup plus à droite il est
lancé il est en réalité il met pas en
cause le capitalisme en tant que tel il
s'en accommode
ce qu'il fait c'est sur le plan sociétal
où il y avait effectivement des carences
très forte un débat qui a eu lieu déjà
en 2016 c'est sur la santé débat qui a
été mal résolu puisque l'obamacare est
toujours là et n'a pas été remplacé par
un plan phénoménal comme nous présenter
donald trump pendant la campagne et
bernie lui prétend avoir un plan
phénoménal qui serait d'offrir à tout le
monde
alors là il se pose le problème du
financement et c'est bien ce que les
républicains vont lire proposé lui
reprocher mais aussi une frange modérée
des démocrates qui vont dire enfin ce
plan là on n'est pas sûr qu'il soit
viable pour tout le monde est-ce qu'à la
fin on va s'en sortir c'est le débat il
va être là dessus il va être vraiment
assez technique assez financiers donc
moi je trouve pas que ce soit le débat
le plus intéressant en réalité si on
oppose l'un à l'autre en réalité avec
joe biden un autre débat c'est savoir si
les modérés républicains vont rester du
côté de donald trump avec lesquels ils
sont aujourd'hui objectivement alors
qu'il ne l'est pas il ya encore un an
aujourd'hui objectivement oui mais s'ils
ont une autre offre qui est modérée et
acceptable pour eux ça serai quoi la
dette et d'un étang républicain
compatibles on va le dire ainsi puisque
hommes du compromis de l'histoire
américaine ça fait 36 ans de sénateur +
8 ans de vice présidence c'est un homme
qui l on s'est habitué les républicains
le connaissent aussi
et là ça j'aimerais donner
trump qui auraient du mal à pouvoir
attaquer cet homme l'avait qu'elle ya
assez peu de prise mise à part
s'attaquer sur son caractère sa
personnalité son bégaiement ses gaffes
mais voyez on est à la marge en réalité
c'est pas ça qui va bouleverser
l'amérique sur sur la gestion au
quotidien et donc les américains
pourraient répondre à cette offre là
c'est plutôt ça qui on mettrait donald
trump d'ailleurs depuis qu ils remontent
comme le dit paul depuis 48 heures on
voit que les attaques contre donald
trump ont repris de plus belle à la fois
de la part de donald trump lui même mais
aussi de toute son armée parce qu'il ne
croise armé lui aussi y'a pas de bernie
sanders et cette armée sur les réseaux
sociaux est ailleurs gracias ici il ya
même une armée il ya ma main s'il ya
même une site qui s'appelle tram sont
remis dans lequel les en demande
non je pars de 30 ha ha excuse-moi
agressés par les autres imprimés bien
cette arme est là et déjà tué des gens
atteints de l'attaqué byden en sentant
que le danger est beaucoup plus grand
avec lui il n'y a pas beaucoup prise
jean eric branaa raison pèlerine pas
beaucoup de prise finalement contre joe
biden il est peu critiquables et
critiquées
jobs a noté le vice président d'obama
pendant huit ans et il ya un moment
choses à critiquer la suisse et ses
résultats dans les affaires étrangères
était horrible et a rien fait de bien et
la turbine pas fort mais il n'est pas
fort et et en séries l'on y avait des
attaques chimiques en série qu'est-ce
que baidu obama fait 0 ils ont déclenché
une guerre en libye
après l'ambassadeur et tuer tuer obile
un buy in était le vice président et
avait cet accord sont avec l'iran son
accord avec le congrès américain des
arts à la russe la russe a attaqué à
cumières
la russie envahi d'ukraine pendant le
vice président de ba dinh
donc il ya plein de choses là et il peut
pas dire que lille est très expérimenté
et a beaucoup beaucoup de succès il n'a
pas déçu
et donc il ya plein champ j'aimerais
bien devoir de bar entre trempé bad où
on l'a vite enterré lui aussi avec son
son premier débat louper il n'empêche
pas ce qu'il pourrait servir d'arbitré
michael bloomberg pour ces primaires
démocrates
c'est ce qu'on attend en réalité demain
matin on va avoir une information qu'on
n'a pas un n'est pas en mesure de donner
aujourd'hui puisqu'on ne sait absolument
pas ce que peut donner blum de
l'apprendre et vous compte 500 millions
de dollars de dépenser une somme moi
j'arrive n'a pas l'imaginer tellement
éloigné est énorme et cet argent
peut-être n'aura servi à rien et
pourquoi est ce que je dis ça parce
qu'on avait déjà un autre milliardaire
tome ce tailleur qui a dépensé lui 200
millions pour rien il n'a pas gagné un
seul délégué est ce que c'est la même
chose avec bloomberg
on n'en sait rien au moment où on parle
certains sondages nous explique qu'il
est en train de gagner dans certains
états on parle de quatre états sur
lequel il serait très haut notamment
l'ugta et le med mais également l'art
quand ça et et l'oklahoma ont pour
l'instant c'est des suppositions les
sondages n'ont pas eu de très bons
résultats jusqu'à aujourd'hui
en tout cas depuis le début de ces
primaires il faut se méfier parce
qu'effectivement il ya des phénomènes
qui n'ont pas vu et là il ou ils nous
annoncent peut-être un phénomène qui
s'il s'avérait juste serait énorme parce
qu'effectivement s'il a réussi avec son
argent as acheté le ticket pour la
maison blanche il s'est passé quelque
chose des états unis mais s'il n'a pas
réussi c'est également une information
est elle à ce moment là on sort avec une
course à deux by john saunders en tout
cas dans quelques heures on sera fixé-
palin justement bloomberg
bon il ya deux candidats et one dans la
course et
toujours dans les comics de sms de jeter
l'épongé après c'est rien du tout il ya
deux en tête et vraiment c'est une
course à deux donc mais tous les deux
vont gagner s'ils gagnent 15% à 2 les
électeurs de voter chaque état ils
gagnent plus sans taj de les délégués
donc c'est très possible que tous les
deux vont gagner des délégués et ça
c'est une chose chacun quelqu'un doit
gagne majorité de votes par le pluralité
la mesure était pour être nominé le
candidat pour le parti démocrate et avec
one et bloomberg
c'est juste il va conduire à minimiser
les chances que soit byden reçoit st 2
vont gagner la majorité et il y aura une
convention juillet contestées dernière
petite question le silence assourdissant
de barack obama c'est normal c'est de
tradition c'est normal il l'avait
annoncé et il l'avait annoncé il ya déjà
un nom en disant qu'il n'interviendrait
pas quoi qu'il arrive dans ce débat
jusqu'à ce qu'il y à un nominé à la
convention de milwaukee ici tient je
trouve ça plutôt mieux pour les
l'ensemble des candidats il n'y a pas de
raison qu'ils favorisent l'un ou l'autre
il est évident que dans la tête de tout
le monde y favorise davantage byden kate
son vice président avec lequel il est
ami donc encore plus pour cette raison
là je trouve que son silence est assez
classe et qui et j'espère qu'il va s'y
tenir
parce que effectivement la course a
besoin d'être la plus transparente
possible
merci à tous les deux parlent d'avoir
été avec nous pour ce face à face